er nehme ich dann noch reichlich zeit
der begrüßung
[Applaus]
36 jahre war in der natur erkennt diese
länder seien auswendig und das genießt
das sicherlich dass er jetzt darüber
reden dafür nicht hinter obama stehen wo
es sollen das sind wirklich seine show
heute abend
oder braucht der kongress seine politik
das weiße der es wird nur noch ein paar
stimmen und seine eigene partei zwei
stimmen aus west virginia und arizona
zwei konservative demokraten und er
braucht diese unterstützung von dieser
zwei senatoren und dann kann er seine
sachen
2,8 millionen politik tisch kriegen
[Applaus]
es ist ihm sicherlich sehr zugute
gekommen dass er eben so lange in der
politische funktion und politischen und
solo gewesen ist jetzt gerade erwähnt
hat man das gemerkt
in diesem jahr
ein bisschen aber ich glaube ja selber
enttäuscht dass es so wenig bringt er
hat gesagt weil es sauber hat selber
geäußert wie polemisierte kommen der
senat jetzt ist das hat er nicht gedacht
der sicherlich viel besser autobahnen
gewappnet ein brücken zu bauen im senat
und wenn er das geschafft denn ich weiß
nicht wie er das schaffen kann
[Applaus]
auf 14 meter präsident zu sein weil er
einfach viel zu wenig erreicht hat und
er wird jetzt einfach nur präsident sein
und daher vielleicht eine andere
strategie eine andere taktik einfach
auch entfalten
er hat gegen den republikanischen partei
gar nichts von ihm unterstützten die
haben gar kein plan server ihr ziel ist
dass ihnen zu verhindern dass er
wiedergewählt wird die haben ein ziel
keine zweite amtszeit für beide
unternehmen
so jetzt sind wir mal rein und sind
gespannt was joe biden nicht nur zur
innenpolitik sondern vor allen dingen
eben auch zur außenpolitik zum krieg in
der ukraine sagt
durch die gleichen
gleich vorweg
franken klar
kein team
ich hier auch werben
danke schon mal vielen dank an sie alle
[Musik]
vizepräsidentin first lady
kongressmitglieder und
regierungsmitglieder sehr geehrte
richter des obersten gerichtshofs liebe
amerikanische landsleute im letzten jahr
hat und scoop.it
wirklich gespalten heute kommen wir
wieder zusammen
[Applaus]
gemeinsam
treffen wir uns hier als demokraten
republikaner und unabhängige und vor
allen dingen als amerikaner wir haben
eine pflicht gegen uns alten gegen uns
untereinander gegenüber und gegenüber
dem amerikanischen volk und unserem land
und wir wissen dass freiheit immer über
die tyrannei siegen wird
mexiko vor sechs tagen
hat russlands wladimir putin beschlossen
die grundlagen der freien welt zu
erschüttern
und er hat sich sehr stark verkalkt
verkalkuliert hatte gedacht er könnte in
die ukraine einmarschieren und die welt
würde vor ihm kapitulieren aber es
stattdessen ist er auf einem widerstand
gestoßen die mit dem er nie gerechnet
hat vor allem den widerstand des
ukrainischen volkes
präsident selensky
[Applaus]
von präsent zielinski bis zu allen
einzeln ukrainern
beobachten wir ein mut der die ganze
welt inspiriert
bürger die panzer mit ihren körpern
aufhalten von
rentnern über lehrer bis zu
veteranen und aktiven soldaten
verteidigen die menschen ihr land und
vieh präsidentiellen ski sagte das licht
wird über die dunkelheit gewinnen die
ukrainische botschafterin ist hier bei
uns sitzt neben der
sitzt neben der first lady und das ist
ein signal an die welt
vielen dank dass sie hier sind
die branche sei
die entschlossenheit und die stärke ist
uns ein beispiel
ja
ja wir die vereinigten staaten von
amerika stehen an der seite des
ukrainischen volkes müssen stolz auf
unsere geschichte und haben daraus
gelernt wenn diktatoren kein preis für
die aggression bezahlen müssen dann
verursachen sie noch mehr chaos sie
gehen dann immer weiter vor und
der protest in amerika und weltweit
steigt an und dafür wurde ja das bündnis
der nato gegründet um den frieden nach
dem zweiten weltkrieg zu sichern die usa
als mitglied gemeinsam mit 29 anderen
nationen wissen dass es auf die das
bündnis ankommen die entschlossen auf
die entschlossenheit kommt es an und
auch diplomatique und des 1 dieser
angriff auf die ukraine war voraus
geplant und völlig unprovoziert es gab
wiederholte anstrengung der diplomatie
und putin dachte der westen die nato
wird nicht reagieren er hatte geglaubt
er könnte uns spalten in dieser kammer
hier und in dieser nation er hatte
geglaubt er könnte uns in europa spalten
aber putin liegt falsch wir sind bereit
wir stehen gemeinsam und vereint und
genau so wird es auch bleiben
wir haben uns sehr ausführlich
vorbereitet wir haben bündnisse
geschmiedet mit den freiheit lieben
nationen und zwischen den ländern
afrikas und asiens und uns um putin uns
entgegen zu stellen wir haben stunden
und stunden und stunden damit verbracht
auch unseren europäischen verbündeten zu
vereinen und wir wussten was putin plant
und wir wussten wie er seine aggression
rechtfertigen würde mit welchem lügen
mit welchem fälschungen und jetzt hat er
gehandelt
die freie welt zieht ihn zur
verantwortung gemeinsam mit 27
mitgliedern der europäischen union
inklusive deutschland frankreich italien
mit dem vereinigten königreich japan
neuseeland und selbst die schweiz
verfügt russland jetzt schmerzen zu und
bestraft dass putin für sein
handeln und er ist isoliert heute in der
welt als er es jemals war
gemeinsam
gemeinsam sind wir mit unseren
verbündeten dabei sehr scharfe
wirtschaftssanktionen zu verhängen
russlands größte banken sind vom
interesse finanzsystem ausgeschlossen
russlands zentralbank an den rubel nicht
mehr verteidigen
630 milliarden dollar in der kriegskasse
von putin sind jetzt nutzlos und wir
bürgen russland zugang zur technologie
abwehrschwächen sein militär für jahre
im voraus heute abend sage ich den
russischen oligarchen und führen die
milliarden von dollar aus diesem regime
gezogen haben so wird es nicht
weitergehen es ist schluss damit und das
meine ich so
[Applaus]
die vereinigten staaten
und justizministerium haben eine task
force gegründet um den verbrechen der
oligarchen zu verfolgen gemeinsam mit
unseren europäischen verbündeten werden
wir ihre yachten ihre privat jets ihre
luxusvillen
beschlagnahmen wir sind euch auf der
spur und wir werden jetzt den wir sind
jetzt verkünden heute den amerikanischen
luftraum für alle russischen flugzeuge
zu sperren und weiteren druck auf die
russische ökonomie auszuüben
[Applaus]
er hat keine vorstellung davon was da
auf ihn zukommt der rubel hat bereits 30
prozent seines wertes verloren die
russische börse hat 40 prozent ihres
wertes verloren und das trading der
aktienhandel bleibt aufge ausgesetzt
putin allein ist derjenige die schulter
an trägt gemeinsam mit unseren
verbündeten
unterstützen wir die ukraine in ihrem
kampf für freiheit
militärische unterstützung
wirtschaftliche unterstützung humanitäre
hilfe wir geben mehr als eine milliarden
dollar aus für die unterstützung der
gewählten vertreter des ukrainischen
volkes und wir helfen ihnen ihr leid zu
mildern und irland zu verteidigen
magnifico er
aber ich möchte klarstellen unsere
streitkräfte
kämpfen nicht in diesem konflikt der
russischen streitkräfte in der ukraine
unsere streitkräfte gehen nicht nach
europa um in der ukraine zu kämpfen um
unsere verbündeten zu verteidigen sollte
putin entscheiden weiter nach westen vor
zu bringen dafür mobilisieren wir
landstreitkräfte die navy die luftwaffe
und wir stärken unsere kontingente in
den baltischen staaten polen in rumänien
die usa und unsere verbündeten werden
jeden soll nato territorium verteidigt
mit der vollen stärke mit der vollen
kampfkraft unserer gemeinsamen stärke
jeden quadrat soll
und
wir sehen die ukraine kämpfen großem mut
zurück in den nächsten wochen und
monaten kommen harte zeiten auf sie zu
putin seht gewalt und chaos aber während
er vielleicht auf dem schlachtfeld raum
gewinnt wird er einen hohen preis
langfristig zahlen und
die stolz das stolze ukrainische volk
ist bereit das eigene land zu verteilen
sie haben jetzt so lange unabhängigkeit
genossen und sie haben immer wieder
gezeigt dass sie nicht tolerieren werden
wenn irgendjemand versucht irland wieder
zurückzuwerfen
und ich bin ehrlich zu ihnen liebe
amerikaner der russische diktator der
ein fremdes land überfällt hat der
ganzen welt jetzt kosten zu gefühlt und
wir sorgen dafür dass unsere sanktionen
die russische wirtschaft schädigen und
für alles in unserer macht stehende tun
um amerikanische verbraucher und
unternehmen zu schützen aber ich kann
ihn sein dass wir mit 30 anderen ländern
daran arbeiten
16 millionen barrel öl aus reserven
weltweit zur verfügung zu stellen
amerika wird diese anstrengung führen
wir stellen auf 13 millionen barrel
unsere eigenen strategischen ölreserve
zur verfügung und wir stehen gemeinsam
seite an seite mit unserer verbündeten
damit werden wir sorgen wenn wir dafür
sorgen dass die spritpreise nicht zu
hoch steigen und will ich möchte dass
sie wissen es wird und gut gehen wir
werden gut aus der sache rauskommen denn
russlands angriff auf die ukraine wird
russland schwächer und den rest der welt
stärker zurück lassen
warten
[Applaus]
aber es hätte nicht so etwas
schreckliches bedurft um den menschen
der welt klar zu machen worum es geht
aber jetzt sieht es jeder wirklich sehr
klar wir sehen die einheit unter den
führenden nationen
stärker vereinigtes europa ein stärker
vereinigter westen gesehen einigkeit
unter den menschen die in den städten
sich versammeln und in riesigen mengen
demonstrieren selbst in russland
demonstrieren die menschen ihre
unterstützung für die ukraine schnell
ukraine im kampf zwischen demokratien
und autokratien stehen demokratien
aufrecht da und verteidigen sich es geht
um frieden und sicherheit und das ist
die echte prüfung das ist der test es
wird zeit dauert lasst uns weiter
inspiration beziehen aus dem eisernen
willen des ukrainischen volkes unseren
amerikanischen landsleuten ich sage ich
will stärken die bande zwischen unseren
nationen wir stehen an ihrer seite
putin kann vielleicht kiew mit panzern
einnehmen aber nie die herzen und köpfe
der der ukrainischen menschen er wird
niemals liebe zur freiheit unterdrücken
können und niemals die entschlossenheit
der freien welt besiegen
wir treffen uns hier heute abend in
einem amerika das zwei der härtesten
jahre hinter sich hat die diese nation
je erlebt hat die pandemie ist
schrecklich und so viele menschen leben
von einem tag zum anderen die kosten für
lebensmittel für sprit für die wohnung
gehen nach oben und ich
verstehe dass sie für mein vater musste
aus kräften pennsylvania aufbrechen und
ja woanders arbeit zu suchen ich weiß
wie sich das anfühlt werden die
lebensmittelpreise steigen und eines der
ersten dinge die ich als präsident
unternommen hat war den american rescue
plan also den wirtschafts förderplan zu
verabschieden wir wussten dass wir
handeln müssen und wir haben gehandelt
du es zwei gesetze haben mehr getan um
uns aus der krise zu führen als andere
nämlich der impfplan zum schutz vor
kurve 19 das hat herr millionen
amerikaner aus der krise geholfen und da
geholfen
wirklich auch die lebensmittel auf den
tisch zu bringen wir haben vorher
gesehen wie lange schlangen für
lebensmittel an still und wir haben die
kosten der gesundheitsversorgung
gesenkt wie mein vater zu sagen pflegte
gebt den leuten einfach ein bisschen
luft zu atmen ein bisschen raum zu atmen
der american rescue plan
die merkelsche american rescue plan hat
den arbeitenden menschen helfen und
niemand geholfen niemanden alleine
zurückgelassen
und es funktioniert das hat funktioniert
und funktioniert weiter
[Applaus]
viele arbeitsplätze wurden geschaffen
unsere wirtschaft hat über 65 millionen
neue arbeitsplätze geschaffen allein im
letzten jahr mehr arbeitsplätze in einem
jahr als jemals zuvor in der geschichte
der vereinigten staaten von amerika
die wirtschaft ist mit um 5,7 prozent
gewachsen die stärkste das stärkste
wachstum in vielen jahren und es gab zu
viele pläne vorher und zu lange solche
pläne die nie für die arbeit der
bevölkerung funktionierte an jetzt haben
wir das umgekehrt wir haben hier wohnt
wurde immer gesagt die
steuererleichterungen für die reichsten
würden herab risiken und den anderen
auch helfen aber wir haben was wir
gekriegt haben war ein größeres
staatsdefizite niedrigere löhne und
wachsende profite der wenigen an der
spitze und wachsende reichtum
vizepräsidentin harris und ich haben uns
beworben um das abend ich weiß dass wir
da auch meinungsverschiedenheiten um
eine neue wirtschaft zu schaffen um die
bildung zu verbessern um die wirtschaft
neu aufzubauen und zwar von unten nach
oben nicht von oben nach unten
weil wir wissen
weil wir wissen wenn die mittelschicht
wächst
dann können die armen aus der armut and
nach oben sich arbeiten und auch den
reichen wird es noch weiter gut gehen
und das betrifft und wir wollen auch
unsere infrastruktur verbessert wir
können doch nicht uns auch das
einundzwanzigste jahrhundert im 21
jahrhundert gut schlagen wenn unsere
infrastruktur so marode ist und ich
danke meinen republikanischen freunden
die sich bereit erklärt mit in die
infrastruktur zu investieren um amerika
wiederaufzubauen die zweitgrößte
investition in der geschichte unseres
landes das war ein
anstrengungen beider parteien ich möchte
damit wir dann beide parteien die das
möglich gemacht haben
wir reden jetzt über eine infrastruktur
jahrzehnt nicht über wenige wochen in
denen das besser werden soll
das wird amerika verwandeln und das wird
uns ermöglichen den
wirtschaftswettbewerb im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert zu
gewinnen den wir indem wir stehen wir
stehen im wettbewerb mit china ich habe
zu ihm gesagt hast du es nicht schlau
ist wogegen das amerikanische volk zu
wetten wir haben viele arbeitsplätze
schaffen wir modernisieren unsere ganze
infrastruktur straßen wasserwegen
schienen und das ganze auch mit einer
umweltgerechtigkeit wir werden
500.000 ladestation für elektrofahrzeuge
im ganzen land verteilen und wir werden
dafür sorgen dass jedes kind jede
familie sauberes wasser in der schule
und zu hause genießen kann
[Applaus]
wir werden dafür sorgen dass es zu
bezahlbaren preisen
schnelle
internetverbindung im ganzen land gibt
verbindungen 4000 projekte
sind hier schon
in verschiedensten bezirken angestoßen
worden und heute möchte ich ankündigen
über
65.000 meilen der straßen und viele
viele brücken werden jetzt modernisiert
und restauriert werden
[Applaus]
wenn wir die steuergelder verwenden um
amerika neu aufzubauen dann tun wir das
in dem wir in amerika einkaufen und zur
amerikanische produkte kaufen
amerikanische arbeitsplätze
unterstützen
die regierung gibt etwa 600 milliarden
dollar aus um uns hier in sicherheit zu
wahren
wir wollen mit steuergeldern aber auch
unsere eigenen arbeitsplätze zu stützen
und schützen
alle sagen immer dass sie das wollen
aber wir tun es tatsächlich wird kaufen
in amerika amerikanische produkte egal
ob es flugzeuge sind stahlträger von
anfang bis ende werden wir das kaufen
was hier in unserem eigenen land
hergestellt wird
aber leute
[Applaus]
beim wettbewerb um die arbeitsplätze der
zukunft müssen wir chancengleichheit
haben im hinblick auf china und andere
wettbewerber deswegen ist es so wichtig
dass beide parteien im kongress diese
reformen mittragen auch was die
herstellende industrie angeht wir haben
fast zwei prozent inland produkt immer
in forschung und entwicklung
investiert aber jetzt müssen wir
weitergehen auch mit blick auf china
schauen wir uns zb ohio an da sind
tausende von hektar land die sehen
vielleicht erst mal nicht nach viel aus
aber wenn man dann ganz genau hinschaut
dann sind das felder voller träume da
kann die zukunft amerikas aufgebaut
werden so wie es in silicon valley war
da werden mit 20 milliarden
dollar werke für
halbleitertechnik eingerichtete als
10.000 neue arbeitsplätze werden so
entstehen um diesen fabriken in diesen
werken
werden über 100.000 dollar
investiert werden für jedes einzelne
projekt was dort im zusammenhang mit der
halbleitertechnologie mit smartphones
mit internet technologien auch mit neuen
innovationen die wir jetzt noch gar
nicht kennen im zusammenhang steht
irgendwo heute
und ist hier bei uns
[Applaus]
kann man zu mir und hat gesagt wir
wollen von 20 milliarden auf 100
milliarden aufstocken was unsere
investitionsbereitschaft angeht das wäre
die höchste einzelinvestition in die
herstellende industrie in der geschichte
unseres landes und das funktioniert wenn
wir dieses gesetz verabschieden also
lassen sie uns nicht länger warten dann
geht es wirklich los
außerdem
[Musik]
ist nur ein beispiel für solche projekte
in amerika aber wir sehen überall
erstaunliche geschichten neue produkte
die hergestellt werden in amerika
amerikanische fertigung neue fabriken
werden hier bei uns gebaut fabriken die
vor einigen jahren noch nach übersee
gegangen wären das ist das was jetzt
hier passiert
elf milliarden dollar werden allein in
die elektrofahrzeug industrie investiert
sieben milliarden dollar zum bau von
elektrofahrzeugen der werden 4000
arbeitsplätze allein in michigan
geschaffen
fast 70.000 arbeitsplätze sind letztes
jahr nur in dieser branche geschaffen
worden
[Applaus]
und zwar dank der kraft von leuten wie
shearer bildes von der stahlarbeiter
gewerkschaft sollte heute abend auch
hier bei uns sein
[Applaus]
oder der senator sherrod brown
brown hat gesagt es wird zeit diese
bezeichnung raesfeld rostgürtel hinter
uns zu lassen
was früher der rast bald war das wird
jetzt die heimat von neuen projekten im
bereich forschung und auch fertig und
das ist unsere neue volkswirtschaft
höhere löhne und gehälter es gibt immer
noch zu viele familien die darum kämpfen
müssen ihre rechnungen bezahlen zu
können es gibt die inflation es gibt
immer wieder besorgnis ich verstehe dass
es ist eine krise die wir immer noch
versuchen unter kontrolle zu bringen
aber wir haben unsere volkswirtschaft
schneller wieder auf die beine gestellt
als irgendjemand erwarten konnte die
pandemie hat uns hart getroffen
und natürlich war es schwierig in den
werken die fertigung aufrecht zu
erhalten
es gab bestimmte schließungen die
natürlich auch die produktion zum
erliegen gebracht haben in bestimmten
bereichen sind fabriken geschlossen
worden und es hat dann einfach länger
gedauert dinge herzustellen und auch sie
dorthin zu transportieren wo sie
gebraucht wurden ein drittel der
inflation ist im letzten jahr auf die
automobilbranche zurückgegangen es gab
nicht genug halbleiterproduktion um die
nachfrage zu decken
besonders gebrauchte fahrzeuge
sind
gehandelt worden wir haben aber doch die
wahl wir können entscheidungen treffen
wir können dagegen steuern wir können
dafür sorgen dass nicht die kosten
steigen sondern die gehälter
und das heißt mehr autos und halbleiter
hier in amerika herstellen mehr
infrastruktur mehr innovation hier in
amerika mehr waren günstiger schneller
hier in amerika besseres leben hier in
amerika
statt uns von den lieferketten abhängig
zu machen stellen wir hier zu hause her
was wir brauchen
[Applaus]
die
produktionskapazitäten unserer
volkswirtschaft werden gesteigert aber
in meinen worten heißt das wir bauen ein
besseres amerika auf
um die inflation zu bekämpfen
sorgen wir für niedrigere defizite
niedrige kosten
wir haben viele fachleute gesagt nach
meinem plan wird die inflation
langfristig dadurch gemindert mein plan
sieht so aus die kosten für
verschreibungspflichtige arzneimittel
werden gesenkt
[Applaus]
zahlen mehr
für dieselben medikamente
von den selben unternehmen hergestellt
als irgendein anderes land weltweit
zehn prozent der menschen haben diabetes
in virginia habe ich einen 13 jährigen
jungen mann getroffen
[Musik]
hier gut aussehen der junge bursche dort
und sein vater hat typ 2 diabetes
und in der familie werden jeden tag
medikamente gebraucht da kostet eine
packung schon zehn dollar
aber die sarrazin
eine
solche gewinnspanne
ich habe mit seiner mutter gesprochen
mit joss mutter und habe von ihr
erfahren sie haben keine ahnung wie
lange sie sich diese medikamente noch
leisten können
teilweise wird er das 30 fache dessen
bezahlt was ein solches medikament
kosten müsste und wie willst du deinem
eigenen kind in die augen sehen wenn du
das weißt dass du diese preise nicht
länger bezahlen können wir josua ist
gerade 13 geworden herzlichen
glückwunsch er hatte gestern geburtstag
und zu george w
[Applaus]
rund 200.000 andere junge menschen die
selber oder deren eltern typ 2 diabetes
haben sollten wir die kosten für deren
medikamente so weit runter setzen dass
sich alle menschen diese medikamente
leisten können die formation unternehmen
machen schon genug gewinne
ich weiß dass wir hier im haus nicht
alle einig darüber sind aber wir sollten
mit maddie kate zusammen dafür sorgen
dass verschreibungspflichtige
arzneimittel
erschwinglich werden das ist alles dafür
bereit
für alle notwendigen medikamente hat der
american rescue plan
vorgesehen dass die kosten selbst zu
tragen sind unter 200 dollar im jahr
bleiben das sollten verma nennte neue
regelungen werden
darüber hinaus sollten wir für familien
die energie preise senkt und natürlich
wollen wir den klimaschutz den
klimawandel stoppen den klimaschutz
fördern aber die energieeffizienz sollte
einhergehen mit steuererleichterungen
saubere energie windenergie
sonnenenergie
elektrofahrzeuge das sollte zu
ersparnissen
85 dollar weniger die sie jeden monat an
der tankstelle lassen
und was können wir noch machen um den
lebensstandard für hart arbeitende
familien zu steigern weniger kosten für
kinderbetreuung
man in amerika in einer großstadt lebt
dann zahlt man bis zu 14.000 dollar im
jahr für jedes einzelne kind für den
bedrohung die soll man denn mit vier
kindern über mehrere jahre das überhaupt
schaffen
ich hatte eltern ich hatte geschwister
ich hatte viel hilfe in der familie aber
wie sollen das denn normale menschen
schaffen die vielleicht keine hilfe
bekommen
ich habe vor
die kinderbetreuungskosten für die
meisten familien auf die hälfte zu
reduzieren
millionen von frauen haben während der
pandemie nicht mehr erwerbstätig
gearbeitet weil sie kein geld für die
kinderbetreuung hatten
und das wieder läuft natürlich dem
wirtschaftswachstum deswegen muss es
langfristig solche
betreuungsangebote geben und auch
erschwingliche wohnungen
deswegen ist es wichtig für alle
familien und niemand der weniger als
400.000 dollar im jahr verdient wird
zusätzliche steuern zahlen nicht einen
penny mehr steuern für all diese
menschen
[Applaus]
vielleicht liege ich falsch aber ich
glaube wenn wir hier geheim abstimmen
würden in diesem haus an während uns
alle einig dass das steuersystem derzeit
ungerecht ist das müssen wir in ordnung
bringe ich möchte niemanden bestrafen
aber wir sollten hier doch
zusammenarbeiten damit die wohlhabenden
ihren gerechten teil beitragen letztes
jahr
[Applaus]
und meine verehrte kongressabgeordnete
wir kommen ja aus diesem land des coop
wird amerika das amerika der großen
unternehmen und
ich habe dennoch 36 jahre immer wieder
meine sich zu verteidigen können es geht
doch nur darum dass die großverdiener
ihren fairen anteil beitragen
40 milliarden sind von den größten
unternehmen an gewinn eingestrichen
worden ohne sie haben praktisch null
steuern gezahlt deswegen
eine klare mindeststeuer für alle
großkonzerne und großunternehmen
übersee hat es bestimmte bewegungen
gegeben um weltweit eine mindeststeuer
für konzerne einzuführen auch wenn
arbeitsplätze und werke nach über sie
verlegt werden können hier noch
milliarden an steuern eingenommen werden
aber dafür müssen wir zunächst diese
schlupflöcher diese gesetzeslücken
schließen ich werde später noch mich mit
den einzelheiten beschäftigen moment
geht es einfach darum ganz klar zu sagen
wir wollen niedrigere kosten für die
familien in unserem land sorgen wir
dafür dass es jetzt passiert
leute
und
ich möchte es auch meine kandidaten für
die vergrößerung verteidigen und
vorstellt mein plan
wird wirklich die familien eltern
familien das leben erleichtern auch das
defizit herunter fahren also wir wissen
ja dass die steuerleistung für
großunternehmen das defizit hochgefahren
hat und es wurde ja
wann hatten wir diese debatten um die
stärke oder nicht stärke der sozusagen
wachhunde die darauf achten dass die
gelder nicht verschwendet und umgeleitet
werden und ich sage euch mit meiner
regierung sind die wachhunde wieder da
milliarden von dollar die für
kleinunternehmen gedacht waren
wurde festgestellt dass wirklich
pandemie betrug durchgeführt wurde und
damit haben wir aufgeräumt
ich denke wir stimmen alle überein
ich würde
jetzt dass die schulden
gesenkt wurden und der einzige präsident
der das defizit jemals und 30 millionen
dollar gesenkt hat ich bin kapitalist
anhänger des kapitalismus aber
kapitalismus ohne wettbewerb ist kein
kapitalismus kapitalismus ohne
wettbewerb ist einfach nur ausbeutung
und treibt die profite nach oben
[Applaus]
und die unternehmen müssen im wettbewerb
stehen
und wenn sie nicht im wettbewerb stehen
dann wird alles nur teurer
also ich habe ja von einigen unserer
republikanischen freunde wie schwierig
es geht ist für die kleinen landwirte
und die familienbetriebe warum es gibt
ja nur vier große fleischverarbeitende
betriebe 4 die also keinen wettbewerb
geben
also während der pandemie haben
einige ausländische firmen hier rekord
profite eingefahren weil sie die preise
um 1000
und wir machen schluss damit dass solche
unternehmen ihre geschäftskunden und die
verbraucher dermaßen ausnutzen können
wenn wall street firmen immer mehr
pflegeheime übernehmen dann kamen wir
festgestellt dass die die qualität der
versorgung sinkt und die preise hoch
geht da müssen wir dafür sorgen dass die
das mit medica und anderen instrumenten
die
pflegeeinrichtungen wieder vernünftig
arbeiten können und damit müssen wir
auch die ausbildung verbessern und dafür
sorgen dass alle
menschen eine faire chance auf einen
ordentlichen job haben wir müssen den
mindestlohn auf 15 dollar pro stunde
anheben und die steuererleichterung für
kinder die steuerfreibeträge für kinder
verbessert
das wird unsere wirtschaft nach vorne
bringen und die familie nach vorne
bringen
will
unsere
unsere first lady die immer noch full
time als lehrerin arbeitet sagt das
beste erfolgsgeheimnis für amerika sind
die community college ist
also da sollten wir weiter investieren
wir müssen unsere arbeitskräfte
investieren und die wirtschaft von unten
nach oben aufbauen und dann können wir
etwas erreichen was wir lange nicht
geschafft haben ein besseres amerika
aufzubauen über zwei jahre hat wird
jetzt alle entscheidungen unseres lebens
zu stark bestimmt und ich weiß dass sie
inzwischen der ganze sache müde sind sie
sind erschöpft sind frustriert und
es gibt millionen menschen die am tisch
sitzen in den familien unter ist ein
leerer stuhl weil sie einen angehörigen
verloren haben die pandemie aber durch
die fortschritte die wir erzielt haben
wegen ihrer widerstandskraft wegen der
instrumente die wir im kongress
bereitgestellt haben kann ich heute
sagen wir schreiten sicher voran hin zu
normalen routinen in unserem leben wir
haben einen neuen höhepunkt erreicht im
kampf gegen coop 19
schwere fälle sind auf dem niedrigsten
stand seit juli letzten jahres vor
wenigen tagen hatte der präsident des
zentrums für seuchenbekämpfung neue
richtlinien veröffentlicht und damit
können wir jetzt ohne masken im freien
herum laufen und basierend auf den
vorhersagen werden wir in den nächsten
wochen sehr viel mehr bereiche haben
indem wir solche fortschritte erzielen
cupid 19 dafür muss er hat jetzt keine
macht mehr über unser leben heute sage
ich heute sage ich dass wir niemals
akzeptieren werden einfach mit 19 zu
leben wir werden das virus weiter
bekämpfen wie wir auch andere
krankheiten bekämpft haben und weil
dieses virus mutiert und sich verbreitet
müssen wir wachsam bleiben und wir
brauchen der vier schritte um sicher
voranzukommen erst
vor sorgen sie dafür dass sie sich durch
impfung und weil und medikamente
schützen wenn sie em geimpft sind und
eine auffrischungsimpfung hatten hatten
werden sie es gut geschützt sein ich
weiß
dass wir jetzt auch impfstoffe für
kinder haben wissenschaftler arbeiten
hart daran auch für kinder unter fünf
sichere impfstoffe bereit zu stellen wir
sind bereit wir stehen bereit auch
antivirale behandlungsmethoden zu
entwickeln
die wir haben schon medikamente die die
chance die gefahr im krankenhaus zu lang
um 90 prozent senken und weise arbeitet
sehr hart daran millionen dosen dieser
doku mit dieser medikamente
bereitzustellen
und jetzt wird kommen wird die
initiative testet reid entwickelt also
vom test zur behandlung also wir können
sofort bei nach einem positiven
testergebnis die antiviralen medikamente
kostenfrei zur verfügung stellen bis 4
cavallo bilden also wir haben auch
behandlungsmittel und
kostenfreie masken bereitgestellt wir
haben hunderte millionen von tests
bereit gestellt und die können sie
kostenfrei bestellen
ich sage sie können auch noch weitere
tests
stellen auf
test.de da können sie noch mehr tests
kostenfrei bestellen zweitens wir müssen
uns auf neue varianten vorbereiten der
vergangenheit
waren wir immer besser geworden doch in
neue varianten zu
identifizieren wir haben neue impfstoffe
in wochen entwickelt statt in monaten
oder jahren und wir brauchen neue
vorräte an test an masken an
medikamenten ich kann eben nichts
versprechen die schnell wird das alles
überwinden aber ich kann ihnen
versprechen dass wir bereit stehen wenn
eine neue variante auf uns zurollt
die schließung von schulen und
unternehmen wird gestoppt das können wir
beenden wir haben die instrumente die
wir brauchen um den lock down zu beenden
und damit
menschen können wieder in die büros
zurückkehren die kinder können die
schulen zurückkehren wir tun als hier in
unseren regierungsgebäuden die große
mehrheit unserer mitarbeiter arbeitet
wieder vor ort in der verwaltung so muss
es weitergehen die kinder müssen in die
schule gehen können
[Applaus]
als amerikaner sind folge durchgeimpft
und die aus vitalisierung rat ist stark
herunter die meisten können jetzt ihre
masken ablegen und sich frei und sicher
bewegen
wir haben frei impfstoffe
behandlungsmethoden tests und masken
bereitgestellt dieses kostenfrei zur
verfügung kostet natürlich geld und
jetzt sind wir hier wieder im regierungs
geschehen die größte mehrheit der
amerikaner hat diese werkzeuge genutzt
und sie werden sie vielleicht wieder
gebrauchen und ich hoffe dass der
kongress schnell ein entsprechendes
gesetz verabschiedet viertens wir müssen
auch die welt weitergeben wir haben
hunderte millionen impfstoffdosen 112
länder gesandt mehr als jede andere
nation auf der welt und wir werden damit
nicht aufhören
[Applaus]
denn man kann keine mauer bauen die hoch
genug ist um
ein virus
aufzuhalten aber eine impfstoff kann die
verbreitung der krankheit und der solche
und wir haben so viele menschen verloren
aber jetzt sollten wir diesen moment
nutzen um ein reset durchzuführen
scoop.it darf auch keine spaltung
zwischen den parteien
verursachen hören wir doch auf uns
gegenseitig als feinde zu betrachten
betrachten wir einander als das was wir
sind gemeinsam amerikanische landsleute
die gemeinsam kämpfen
[Musik]
fri
schauen sie
wir können jetzt nicht verändern wie
gespalten wie gespalten wir waren aber
wir können das künftig besser machen den
eco mit 19 krise müssen wir gemeinsam
bekämpfen
sich
nämlich an die beerdigung der beiden
polizeioffiziere die in der ausübung
ihrer pflicht getötet wurden als ein
mann sie mit einem gestohlenem so wer
erschoss
es waren junge polizistin und
beide
sind in den straßen auf in denselben
straßen aufgewachsen die sich später als
polizisten beschützt haben ich habe mit
den familien gesprochen und ich habe ihm
gesagt dass wir immer in ihrer schuld
stehen für ihr opfer und wir weiter
daran arbeiten das vertrauen und die
sicherheit unserer gemeinwesen
wiederherzustellen
ich frage ja mit einigen von ihnen schon
lange zusammengearbeitet zu diesem thema
nicht weiß dass es funktioniert wir
können
verbrechens vorbeugung verbessern
mit
ortspolizisten die viertel gut kennen
die die menschen kennen wir müssen nicht
zwischen sicherheit und gerechtigkeit
wählen entscheiden nein es geht beides
natürlich müssen auch polizisten zur
rechenschaft gezogen werden die sich
fehlverhalten
also
deswegen hat american rescue player
auf 350 milliarden dollar bereit
gestellt um den polizisten die zu
ermöglichen überhaupt ihren job zu
machen indem sie die notwendigen
ausrüstungsgegenstände haben und eine
richtige strategie entwickeln können
bewährte strategien wie gewalt
bekämpfung um dem teufelskreis der
gewalt zu durchbrechen in den
verschiedenen stadtviertel die antwort
ist nicht der polizei geld zu streichen
und so der polizei mehr geld zur
verfügung zu stellen die polizei muss
finanziert werden
[Applaus]
mit ressourcen und mit ausbildung
die brauchen ausbilden damit sie unser
gemeinwesen wir schützen können ich habe
demokraten und republikaner gebeten
mein haushalt zu verabschieden um unsere
stadtviertel sicher zu machen und wir
wollen hart vorgehen gegen den illegalen
waffenhandel waffen die man deren
bestandteil man online ordern und dann
zuhause zusammensetzen kann das müssen
wir bekämpfen
wir brauchen doch maßnahmen gegen die
waffengewalt
universelle hintergrund schecks müssen
durch gefühl müssen verabschiedet und
beschlossen werden wie kann man denn
jemand waffen kaufen lassen der einen
terroristischen hintergrund hat
also es geht werden jetzt waffen
verkauft mit magazin mit bis zu 100
schuss die rasen stadt abgefeuert werke
braucht man das
sind doch sonst immer mit dem
verbraucherschutzgesetz und so stark
aber waffenproduzenten werden die zur
rechenschaft gezogen
die haften nie für das was ihre produkte
anrichten und sind die einzige branche
bei der das so ist wir können dadurch
neue gesetze verabschieden das wahlrecht
ist das wichtigste recht was wir haben
und damit können wir andere zur
rechenschaft ziehen
und jetzt werden in start für staat neue
gesetze verabschiedet die die
wahlfreiheit einschränken die ganze
wahlen verzerren wie kann denn sowas
passiert wie können wir das zulassen ich
rufe den senat auf der das gesetz zur
verteidigung der wahl des wahlrechts zu
verabschieden das war echt wird überall
eingeschränkt dagegen müssen bekämpfen
und wir müssen auch ein gesetz
verabschieden das den amerikanern
ermöglicht zu sehen wer eigentlich die
wahlen finanziert
heute haben wir jemand der sein leben
dem dienst am land gewidmet hat richter
breyer armee veteran
und ein
ehemaliger richter am obersten
gerichtshof vielen dank ihre dienst am
volk
vielen dank
wir wissen alle
[Applaus]
woran man machen glaubt eine der
wichtigsten
verfassungsmäßigen pflichten ist die
nominierung einer person um am obersten
gerichtshof der usa
zu dienen und ich habe nun
katja braun jackson dominiert den
appellation
[Applaus]
und richter weiß
erbe wird damit sicherlich exzellent
fortgeführt
jemand der praktische erfahrung hat der
pflichtverteidigung absolviert hat sie
hat auch erfahrung darin konsens zu
schaffen
und zusammen zu arbeiten mit der polizei
mit den verschiedenen politischen
parteien leute wenn wir freiheit und
gerechtigkeit fördern
dann müssen wir unsere grenzen sichern
und das einwanderungsgesetz
verbessern
sie können sich denken ich glaube dass
wir beides zusammen legen können wir
haben neue technik an den grenzen zum
beispiel ganz moderne scanner um den
drogenschmuggel zu unterbinden
aber auch
dass auch gewaltverbrechen gegen
bestimmte familien unterbunden werden
können so dass menschen die ganz legitim
sich hier in unserem land aufhalten
natürlich hier bleiben können und andere
aber zurückgeschickt werden wir können
das alles tun und gleichzeitig die
fackel der freiheit hochhalten
meine vorgänger und viele ihrer
vorgänger haben diesen weg bereitet und
natürlich gilt das auch für unsere
dreamers für die kinder illegal
eingewanderter deren status geschützt
bleiben soll
familien sollen nicht erzählte warten
müssen bis sich eltern und kinder wieder
sehen können wir wollen auch das tun was
wirtschaftlich sind deswegen sind solche
reformen wichtig für die
einwanderungsgesetze auch für die
arbeitsmarktgesetze wir sollten das
jetzt ein für alle mal vernünftig regeln
[Applaus]
freiheit und gerechtigkeit fördern und
schützen heißt auch die rechte der
frauen schützen
wir haben jetzt ein halbes jahrhundert
lang beobachtet wie die rechte der
frauen beschnitten eingegrenzt
gedrängt wurden und jetzt wollen wir
wirklich endgültig damit aufräumen und
es soll auch eine vernünftige
gesundheitsversorgung insbesondere für
mütter geben überall in amerika
und auch bei lg kritik
angelegenheiten sollten wir die
unterstützung beider parteien vereinen
wo mir die rechte der menschen die
rechte der familien zu schützen
besonders bei jüngeren transgender
personen in amerika ist es wichtig dass
wir auch gesetzlich dafür sorgen dass
diese menschen die volles potenzial
entfalten können und sein können wer sie
selbst nun einmal sind
[Applaus]
schon von mir gesagt wir sind uns nicht
immer alle
und
aber auch viel mehr als wir immer wieder
in der öffentlichkeit
diskutieren und 3 treten ich habe über
80 gesetze abgezeichnet letztes jahr
gegen hass verbrechen für mehr
gerechtigkeit
fortsetzung von initiativen die
teilweise vor drei jahrzehnten schon
angestoßen
aber es ist wichtig dass das volk sieht
dass wir uns hier zusammenfinden dass
wir eine agenda für das ganze land das
ganze schuld haben wir können großes
bewirken zunächst einmal diese pandemie
tatsächlich besiegen da gibt es so viel
zu tun
mehr geld für prävention für behandlung
aber auch abschaffen
überholte regeln
müssen auch dafür sorgen dass es keine
illegalen medikamente mehr gibt
sie müssen natürlich auch die
suchtbekämpfung unterstützt wenn sie ein
suchtproblem haben
sage ich ihnen ich glaube daran dass man
das überwinden kann es gibt über 20
millionen menschen die das schon
geschafft haben
und es gibt wie gesagt dieses
rettungspaket
dass zb die schulen das geld bekommen
die finanziellen mittel bekommen die sie
brauchen
wo sie aber zb sich auch ehrenamtlich
einbringen können aber auch nicht nur
als lehrkraft einbringen können sondern
zum beispiel auch im sinne einer
sozialen und pädagogischen betreuung
gegen die verschiedenen verbrechen die
tatsächlich auch an diesen schulen
stattfinden wir haben heute bei uns fans
haben und sie gehört zu denen die sich
ehrenamtlich einbringen für die gute
sache
[Applaus]
vielen dank
für ihren es werden nun
datenschutzrechte genauso wichtig und
ernst genommen hier wie die rechte der
kinder kinder
müssen geschützt werden
das gilt natürlich auch für das
gesundheitswesen für die versorgung für
die
krankenversicherung aber auch die
behandlung auch im fall von psychischen
erkrankungen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das nächste thema
wir müssen die ehemaligen
armeeangehörigen die weiteren
unterstützen wir müssen für sie da sein
sie sind die besten von uns allen ich
habe immer daran geglaubt dass es eine
heilige pflicht ist sich um diejenigen
zu kümmern die man in den krieg
geschickt hat und auch sich um deren
familien zu kümmern wenn sie nicht
zurückgekommen sind und deswegen gibt es
für die veteranen organisation sie
kostenlose
versorgungsangebote es gibt ja sehr
viele risiken sehr viel gefahren denen
sie ausgesetzt waren viele
gesundheitliche probleme und im irak in
afghanistan
sind
veteranen wie einer der jetzt hier bei
uns ist teilweise 40 mal im einsatz
gewesen
sie haben gelitten sie haben viele
risiken durchlebt und dann kommen sie
nach hause und sie sind nie wieder so
wie zuvor hält sie leiden unter
kopfschmerzen aber auch unter übelkeit
und
gleichgewichtsstörungen
[Musik]
mein sohn ist einer derjenigen
die in der nähe eines feuers im irak und
auch im kosovo so stark gelitten haben
unter den zeugen der ereignisse dort
er hat dadurch krebs bekommen haben und
versucht herauszufinden was sie tun
können was alles möglich ist um solchen
menschen zu helfen
auch anderen armeeangehörigen angehörige
der nationalgarde
die
[Musik]
teilweise brandherde so groß wie
fußballfelder erlebt haben
dazu gehört eine veteranin hier
die heute bei uns ist
[Applaus]
man
hat ebenfalls eine krebserkrankung
erlitten aufgrund der folgen der
kampfhandlungen
die gemeinsame tochter
wir haben uns überlegt dass wir alle
zusammen dafür sorgen wollen dass solche
wird rennen und wird daran ihre familien
noch mehr unterstützung bekommen
die geldzahlungen gekommen
dass vor allem diejenigen die
atemwegserkrankung und krebs
erkrankungen der atemwege haben aufgrund
solcher
brandherde im irak und in afghanistan
endlich die gesundheitliche versorgung
bekommen die ihnen zusteht
[Applaus]
und der nächste und letzte
bekämpfen wir den krebs besiegen wir den
krebs so wie wir ihn bisher kennen das
ist für mich ein persönliches thema
die länderkammer das ist für mich
aber auch
viele andere hier ein sehr persönliches
thema viele haben ihre engsten
angehörigen heute sich aufgrund von
krebserkrankungen verloren das ist die
zweithäufigste todesursache nach
herzerkrankungen in amerika
todesfälle durch krebs bedingt sind in
den nächsten jahren deutlich zu
dezimieren krebs gehört zu den
erkrankungen die behandelbar sind
wir wollen die kranken und auch ihre
familien
unterstützen mit speziellen mitteln
und auf forschungsprojekten mit einer
speziellen behörde im bereich der
gesundheitsbehörden wir wollen auch mit
modernen technologien mit dem internet
mit gps und bei anderen technischen
möglichkeiten dafür sorgen dass die
sicherheit erhöht
wo forschungs durchbrüche in der
forschung krieg über den krebs über
diabetes und andere krankheiten sie sind
möglich wir haben diese möglichkeit und
ich weiß nicht warum nicht alles was ich
hier aufgezählt habe möglich sein sollte
liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger wir
sind heute hier zusammengekommen
dies kam an einem einzigartigen fort in
einer einzigartigen demokratie in
unserer hauptstadt wir haben immer
wieder im laufe
der epochen um die freiheit und für die
freiheit gekämpft
wir haben diskutiert wir haben gekämpft
gegen den terror und wir waren immer da
freiheitlichste und wohlhabendsten
nationen weltweit und jetzt ist der
moment gekommen wo wir unsere
verantwortung
wahrnehmen müssen wir unsere
entschlossenheit auf die probe gestellt
wird die geschichte als solche zeigt
sich jetzt hier als prüfstein für
unseren charakter als nation unsere
zukunft wird sich hier entscheiden
ich kenne unser volk wir werden diese
probe bestehen
und wir werden eine chance daraus machen
wir werden die demokratie retten zu
schwierige zeiten auf sind ich bin
optimistisch und ich würde mein eigenes
leben auf unser land verwetten wenn ich
weiß es gibt nichts was wir nicht
schaffen können wir sind das einzige
volk weltweit das aus jeder krise eine
chance gemacht hat das einzige volk das
sich selbst definiert durch nur ein
konzept das konzept der möglichkeiten es
gibt so viele nationen
und zur lage unserer nation sage ich
heute wie das amerikanische volk sind
stark wir alle sind stark heute stärker
heute sind wir stärker als noch vor
einem jahr
und wir werden in einem jahr noch
stärker sein als wir heute sind das ist
unser moment in der geschichte jetzt
müssen wir die herausforderungen unserer
zeit bewältigt und das werden wir als
ein volk ein amerika die vereinigten
staaten von amerika gott schütze sie
alle und möge gott unsere truppen
beschützen vielen dank
[Applaus]
und wir sprechen aber diese rede mit
jeff mason den ich noch mal herzlich
begrüßen ist das was wir jetzt gehört
haben das was sie erwartet haben was
auffiel war er hat mit der ukraine
begonnen er hat ungefähr zehn minuten
zur ukraine gesprochen der rest war
innenpolitik
ich genau ja das ist ungefähr was ich
erwartet habe auch dass er gleich mit
ukraine angefangen hat damit habe ich
auch gerechnet und wie sie gesagt haben
zehn minuten das zeigt wie wichtig das
thema war für ihn und
und dass ich was ich von hier zu sehen
hatte auch sehr wichtig für alle in dem
raum in dem saal war und das ist gut
angekommen würde ich sagen was ich dazu
gesagt hat und dann wie sie erwähnt
haben
fingern über seine innenpolitik
zufrieden und das war natürlich für
seine partei die demokraten etwas da hat
er etwas mehr unterstützung bekommen als
von den republikanern das war auch zu
erwarten dass große
infrastrukturprogrammen projekt was er
durchsetzen will das hat er sehr
ausführlich beschrieben da verspricht er
den amerikanern sozusagen eine ganz neue
ein ganz neues amerika mit einer
infrastruktur die funktioniert wo
internet funktioniert wo die highways in
ordnung sind und so weiter das haben wir
sicherlich von anderen präsidenten ja
auch schon oft gehört aber er muss
dieses programm erstmal umsetzen
gut genau ich meinen das programm oder
das gesetz hatte jetzt schon
durchgesetzt und bekommen und wie sie
jetzt sagen jetzt muss das das muss das
einfach angefangen werden in den usa
jetzt gehen in verschiedene
bundesstaaten zu realisieren er möchte
natürlich auch teile von seiner
sogenannten bild berg das gesetz
wieder zu leben
das wird auch für ihn nicht nicht
einfach sein aber das hat ja auch heute
abend etwas versucht wieder wieder
anzufahren gab es eine überraschung
nein würde ich nicht sagen heute abend
es gibt manchmal überraschungen wenn
präsidenten ihre stelle junien reden
geben auf jeden fall bei präsidentenpaar
am zumal
überraschungen so zu sagen gehabt aber
heute abend nein also ich glaube was er
was seine hauptthemen waren damit haben
wir alle gerechnet er hat nix großes
neues gesagt apropos bei seiner politik
aber er hat auf jeden fall versucht das
land die leute die menschen dort im
capitol und auch in den usa
zusammenzubringen und das wahr ist ist
eigentlich immer sein thema
anfang letztes jahr ist und jetzt zur
frage bezieht sich jetzt auf die
amerikaner wie haben die die rede
aufgenommen haben eben schon darüber
gesprochen dass es durchaus zwar jetzt
kann unbedingt ein quotenhit aber
immerhin eine rede die man sich in den
usa anguckt wie bei den amerikanern
ihrer einschätzung nach angekommen
mussten wir erst abwarten wie viele
leute wie viele menschen heute abend
zugeschaut haben aber normalerweise
schauen viele märkte die solche reden zu
ich gehe davon aus dass und wir haben
das jetzt auch gesehen ist viele märkte
unterstützen das was er in der ukraine
macht und wie schon erwähnt haben er hat
zehn minuten darüber gesprochen wie die
anderen punkten von seiner rede ankommen
müssen wir einfach abwarten
ganz herzlichen dank in die usa da kann
sie